hey ray
hey grant what's up
hey you would not guess this
our credit watch app the traffic has
been exploding the last few months with
all the viewers checking out our cute
animals
and our product manager martin he's
requested we introduce some real-time
functionality in our cloud run web app
specifically we're looking to add
real-time chat
wow that sounds really cool
however i'm not sure where to start from
the technical side of things i mean
there's http push grpc
web sockets service events
polling etc
oh i can help let's walk through our
options
[Music]
when it comes to real-time communication
with services there are a couple options
server sent events
websockets and grpc
server set events use the http protocol
to create a persistent
one directional connection to send data
from the server to the client
server sent events are great for apps
where you don't need to send any data to
the server
oh that sounds really good especially
for like a twitter style news feed or
maybe like a real-time dashboard of
stock quotes
but in this case we need a chat app to
have bi-directional communication
what are the other options
well cloud run also supports websockets
which allows us to open a two
directional
connection between the client and server
both the client and server can trigger
communication with one another and both
can send messages at the same time oh
that sounds amazing but wait there is
more you also mentioned grpc which can
also enable bi-directional communication
but it uses http
2 protocol and a remote procedure call
framework
though there is a web proxy for browser
server communication
grpc is mostly used for communication
between back-end services so in this
case for a two-way chat app i would
recommend websockets
okay that all sounds really clear oh
thanks
so let's go and look at the code
so it looks like in martin's chat app we
use websockets using socket io
so how does this work
socket io is a nice wrapper for
websockets and provides some additional
features
just like using the websocket api
directly we will install and initialize
socket i o on both the client and the
server
the server will listen for the
connection event which allows us to
access the socket instance on both the
client and server
the socket instance can emit and listen
for messages
all right cool so how do i then deploy
this on cloud run
one of the great parts about websockets
is it comes out of the box with cloud
run
i can deploy this straight from my
terminal using gcloud which can also
handle containerizing the application by
specifying my source directory
now that it's deployed let's test it out
by logging into a chat room
oh awesome
and it looks like martin's already in
the app
oh uh however there
seems to be an issue messages are
disappearing between sessions
uh do you know how to fix that avery
i think i know what the problem is
cloud run automatically scales container
instances and load balances
every request between the available
instances
therefore your client may be connecting
to a different container instance and we
haven't set up any way to share or store
the data
so i guess we need to
save the chat messages to a database
well a database doesn't quite solve this
problem because you need to pull the
database for updates
but we can avoid pulling all together by
using a publisher subscriber broker like
redis
container instances can publish to a
specific channel as well as subscribe
for push updates
okay so uh yeah that sounds good
how then do we add that
first i'll go create a redis instance
for us to use via cloud memory store
our redis instance lives in a virtual
private cloud which means it's not
accessible from the outside internet
so i'll also have to go create a
serverless vpc access connector so our
cloud run service can connect to our
redis instance
when we redeploy we'll need our redis ip
and the name of our serverless vpc
access connector can you update the app
to subscribe and publish to the redis
channels
well using socket io all i had to do was
update it to use the redis adapter
and it handles broadcasting events to
all clients regardless of what container
instances they are connected to
we can connect to the redis instance
with the ip and port environment
variables
when deploying our cloud run service
let's deploy our changes and specify our
new redis environment variable and the
vpc connector
oh
it works
that was easy
i'm so glad we got it working
i'm so glad too and now i know the
difference between server-side events
websockets and grpc
it's so easy to use websockets with
cloudrun to add real-time chat to
martin's app
and don't forget with websockets and
redis we're able to store and coordinate
our data with thousands of users across
all of our container instances
well thanks so much avery i'm sure
martin will be very happy
uh it looks like i have a lot of
messages to reply to
um
yeah let me get to that
awesome see you next time
see ya
[Music]
you